maria dolores mercado has been coming to
the church of baklaran in the capital
manila
since she was a little girl but on the
holiest day of the christian calendar
this is as far as she's allowed to go as
in many countries
places of worship are seen as potential
hubs
for spreading coronavirus so for now
attending mass
is different for me this is enough for
now
that i am able to hear mass outside the
church his words
give me strength my faith is my guide
the church of baklaran has long been the
refuge for the faithful
who come from the poorest sector of
society
but public easter gatherings have been
restricted for a second consecutive year
raising concerns from many catholics
here
that the pandemic may have permanently
altered the ways
of worship the philippines has seen a
steep rise in corona virus cases since
february
prompting the government to impose
another round of lockdown
in manila and nearby provinces but
in recent days at least one out of four
filipinos who have been tested
have turned out positive with
coronavirus
so this priest has been left with no
choice but to preach in an empty church
although it could be watched online he
called for a moment of silence to
remember the thousands who have died
from the pandemic
sending a message of comfort to those
who are grieving
in another part of manila father flavi
villanueva runs a center for the poor
and homeless he talks about redemption
in the critical role the church can play
in society
especially when society fails to respond
appropriately
competently and justly to the needs of
the people
the church cannot remain silent it will
always serve as
a conscience of those brazen
people the church will always remain as
a light
to those dampened by their hopes
kneeling before a homeless man a
reformed drug user
a lawyer and a journalist father flabby
says
they represent those who have been
persecuted by the government
he offers a message of hope but for many
here the shadow of death
still lingers though the faithful say
they remain
fervent in their prayers christ they say
has been resurrected
and they hope filipinos will soon rise
from their sufferings
too jamal lindogan al jazeera manila